hey tell me this you've played with some
great players
some amazing players
who is your starting five
teammates that you've played with
throughout your career and and on the
same team no no throughout your whole
career you had to assemble a starting
five
you're not on the team though
Durant
um
Iverson
Colby of course
LeBron power that's right wait wait I'm
talking about guys you played with oh
your teammates don't wanna play on the
Lakers with or play with that one time
throughout your career and you played
with that one time it was all on my team
one time LeBron USA
Durant USA okay take the USA [ __ ] out
Kobe well let's go through Miami Colby
Powell Dallas Kobe Powell
Kobe Powell
Dwyane Wade
yeah
um
Dirk Nowitzki [ __ ] yeah this is the
all-time great team Colby
you kind of well you don't necessarily
need it pal
you had Jason Kidd on that map
Dwyane Wade
Dirk
I mean Vince Carter oh he had Vince on
the yeah
you put Vince over Jason Kidd
ing yeah I know I got time but not
overall right at that time
that's a hell of a tip you played that's
all to say though yeah and then you're
the Sixth Man however you want to take
it yeah
that's crazy that'd be that'd be a
pretty wild uh